father Smith warrior mother maiden Crone
stranger is
she is mine hey everybody it's Charlie
so I've been getting a lot of requests
for new Game of Thrones Season eight
it's been kind of quiet lately but we
just got some really cool news wilf
scolding the actor that plays Rhaegar
Targaryen on the TV show was just seen
boasting about checking into the same
Belfast hotel that the actor that plays
euron greyjoy
is staying out right near the paint hall
where they're filming all the really big
King's Landing season 8 scenes so
there's been lots of talk about the
King's Landing stuff they've been
filming lately but this Rhaegar thing is
brand new so if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos will we do in season
8 bonus videos till we start to get new
footage which actually isn't that far
off they will continue to film right up
into the summer so obviously there's a
bunch of big battles that they still
have to film they still have the final
battle of the final episode but for the
most part they're gonna be winding down
in the next couple of weeks meaning that
if they have all their principal
photography they'll have enough footage
to cut together for a comic-con trailer
this summer so I'll dress that at the
end of the video too but the cool thing
you know we all kind of hope that there
would be more flashbacks in season eight
Rhaegar Targaryen showing up just
casually like it's no big deal
boasting about Game of Thrones as he's
checking into a notable hotel that most
of the Game of Thrones actors stay at
when they go to Belfast to film scenes
in King's Landing just implies that we
might be getting some of that now a lot
of people have pointed out too that
there are a number of reasons for the
Game of Thrones actors to be in Belfast
but there's just so many coincidences
that have to line up that it almost
feels too good to be true so let's talk
about Rhaegar flashbacks during season 8
stuff that we have not seen yet you have
to remember that most of the flashbacks
the last couple of seasons have been
through Brandt's character as he's using
his ability given to him by the
three-eyed Raven the last really big
non-brand flashback that we had was at
the beginning of season 5 where Cersei
was flashing back to when she was a
child getting the prophecy from Maggie
the frog and the show did its version of
the valonqar but by that point bran had
already made it to the three-eyed Ravens
tree so after that it was a brand
literally going into the past using the
weirwoods to see what had actually
happened per the show's explanation he
doesn't
exactly how to control it so he will
just flash back into the past at random
sort of like having a cable subscription
with infinite channels but no channel
guide so that's where Samwell comes in
during season seven is that he's sort of
like the channel guy the Google search
bar that helps brand search for very
specific things instead of just going at
random the Raigarh flashbacks that we've
had so far are all in furtherance of
telling us who Jon Snow is and what his
relationship to the Targaryen family is
so per their explanation at the end of
season seven and Gilley's careful
research accidentally thumbing through
those books
Rhaegar annulled his marriage to Elia
Martell married Lyanna stark then they
had baby Aegon and Samwell and bran
realized that he has a legitimate claim
to the Iron Throne so they're just a
couple of slam-dunk easy flashbacks they
could do with Rhaegar in furtherance of
that storyline or a couple of other
storylines just mirroring some of the
action of season eight we know there's
going to be a struggle between Jon Snow
and Daenerys once they realize how
related they are technically she sees
aunt even though they care deeply about
each other you could say that they love
each other I don't know if that was
exactly explicit in their look they care
about each other deeply
Jon will probably still want to be with
her even after finding out that they're
related but it will be one of the big
conflicts early in the season hopefully
bran does not wait too long to drop that
bomb maybe like at the end of the first
episode after they make it to Winterfell
and have all the introductions oh and by
the way she's your aunt
you totally been doing it with your aunt
this whole time then comes the
realization from the characters that Jon
Snow now has a legitimate claim to the
Iron Throne that is possibly more
illegitimate than ten Eris's so they
could always do more flashbacks this
sort of clarify why Jon is legitimate
and why his claim might be stronger than
Daenerys is in furtherance of the drama
between the two of those characters even
though Jon does not want the Iron Throne
use it to remember that the flashbacks
typically serve the plot in present-day
and some furtherance of that but
mirroring the action of present-day
you also have the death of Rhaegar at
the Battle of the Trident against Robert
so you have this big conflict or two big
conflicts technically because you have
the North versus the night king or the
realm versus the night king however you
want to think about it then you have Jon
and Daenerys as combined forces versus
search
which now we can say is a nice parallel
for the Baratheon versus Targaryen of
Robert's rebellion predating the show so
they've been all kinds of jokes about
how Jon Snow throws himself in harm's
way and has been trying to kill himself
and every chance like he'll stay behind
like no no no you all board the dragon
and get away while I stay here and give
my life to you plot armors too thick
he's brought back after being stabbed by
the Brothers of the Nights Watch he's
brought back after falling into this icy
lake after almost getting taken down by
the night king so if Jon Snow is going
to fall during some big battle that
could be a mirror for Rhaegar falling at
the Trident there's also a lot of
conjecture about what ray gars final
words were when Robert killed him like
he was whispering a woman's name now we
believe it to be Liana because we know
about their relationship and more
explicit terms but for a long time there
was a big mystery about what happened in
the final moments when Rhaegar was
standing out with Robert like were they
just fighting each other did Rhaegar
ever tried to explain to Robert what was
going on and Robert didn't listen to him
the more truth we start to learn about
Rhaegar and Lyanna the more Robert
starts to look like a villain but then
there's also the potential that we could
get more Rhaegar flashbacks that explain
why he was so obsessed with the prophecy
because most of the flashbacks that
we've gotten specific to his character
just have to do with who Jon Snow is
who's this character we've been
following this whole time he's the son
of the crown prince of Westeros in this
stark girl that Ned refused to talk
about even to his wife Catelyn so if
your big book reader you know all about
ray guards obsession with the prophecy
in how he believed that John would be
the Song of Ice and Fire even though the
TV show omits a lot of things from the
books I think it bears that the TV show
should give you a moment that explains
why Jon is so important not so much the
relationship drama of it all because
that's what we've been getting but the
prophecy of it all that explains you
know big picture why he believed that
this was such an important thing like he
married Liana because he was in love
with her we get that but there was also
this other reason why he believed that
she was important too because a child
that they might have could be the
fulfillment of a prophecy that he'd been
thinking about for almost his entire
life given everything we know about his
backstory from the books it'll just be
interesting to see how the TV show
decides to contextualize a lot of his
decision made
that was one of the big things after we
got that scene - it's like how come they
didn't just send a raven to someone to
tell everyone what was going on there
was this huge rebellion that started
because of what they did now this is not
to say that there wouldn't have been a
rebellion anyway because a lot of the
lords had grown very dissatisfied with
the Mad King but then running off
together was one of the things that
started the ball rolling down the hill
one of many factors that led to Robert's
rebellion but in related news speaking
of Robert's rebellion I know people
always want that to be one of the
prequels they've already confirmed that
it's not going to be but George R Martin
talked about the official release date
for his fire and blood book I've already
done a video about that but he did imply
that some of the plot of that might be
used for one of the prequel TV shows
that they're developing the weird thing
too is is that they have five that are
in development right now one of the
other people that's developing one of
those five also made this weird comment
where he talked about wouldn't it be
interesting to see what's happening in
the future of Game of Thrones after
events right now on the TV show so for
the most part we've thought that the
successor series is going to be a
prequel just because there's all this
history that George our Martin has
written and he did make comments that
very specifically said that he wanted to
help Shepherd the successor series so
it's not like HBO is just gonna make up
whatever they want to make up and call
it Game of Thrones it's directly adapted
from Martin's material that he will help
supervise so you have to keep in mind
that there are five separate ideas that
are all very different within that
context so there's still a lot of
possibilities in this fire and blood
book that they're releasing this
November the history of the Targaryen
family really only covers about half of
the Targaryen Kings between Aegon the
conquerer and then Aegon the third HBO
originally said that the prequel series
would debut the year after the main
series ended so we just assumed that it
was going to be 2020 but Martin did
confirm that dates right now we can just
mark our calendars for April May 2020
until HBO gives us some more specific
information but because of how long it
takes to produce seasons of television
they will be shooting that relatively
soon so we'll have a much better idea
for what it's gonna look like what the
costumes were gonna be so thank you
George our Martin for confirming prequel
series in 2020 so something to look
forward to after the main series ends
right now because Comic Con is at the
end of July it seems like that are on
track to release some sort of behind
this
work print footage I wouldn't expect a
really shiny teaser till the end of the
year just because it takes him a while
to finish those special effects but
putting teasers together for the most
part isn't that hard for them to do like
they've been shooting for almost six
months now so they have a ton of footage
that they could show off so no worries
but we won't hear about more specific
Game of Thrones Comic Con news till
later this summer so don't worry
whenever they announce something I'll do
a new video about it so he also like
hers would say confirmed that there will
be no winds of winter in 2018 but I
think we already knew that so I will say
there is a new round of the DVD giveaway
we also have like a 4k season 1 DVD
that's coming out soon so why don't we
just make the giveaway for that because
that'll be dropping this summer all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video while you wait for everything
click here for more season 8 and click
here to learn more about what's going on
with The Witcher TV show thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight